mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs la
radiodiffusion française présente en
émission en différé
au soleil du mexique
opérette en deux actes d'andré oisillons
et albert willemetz musique de maurice
yvain
en voici la distribution niño où il lit
clément jérôme phrase 14 norris portera
mast bec rené schmitt tampico gilbert
mort à matha longue gorge fois morelos
jacut pruvost clark géniaux le chef
d'état doit fils pierre roy
c'est jeanine michaud qui sera jesse
thompson christian-jaque un juanita
charlotte vacquiers qu'aux colonies
marcel sansonnetti la supérieure les
textes de liaison sont de denise votre
mise en ondes musicales jean etienne
marie enregistrement pierre rivel les
solistes et orchestre radio lyrique et
les choeurs de la radiodiffusion
française chef des choeurs marcel
briclot sont placés sous la direction de
gilles gressier
au coeur du mexique sous le chaud soleil
la belle à fiennes da de da mata longo
est aujourd'hui envahie par un grand
nombre d'invités
désireux d'assister au des rides c'est à
dire à la présentation haut débit de
choses ou tooro de l'année
la ganaderia de maths à langon l'élevage
des taureaux de combat est en effet
remarquable aussi les aficionados les
amateurs de tauromachie et leur élégante
compagne se pressent style sur les
terrasses de la propriété les bouviers
défilent devant à te et pour fêter leur
passage les danses nationales se
déchaîne
bravo seuil en boîte à longueau avec de
paris gaillard nous allons assister un
magnifique galerie dont un pic j'espère
que mes élèves se montreront digne de
votre confiance vous savez quel prix
j'attache à votre estimons je suis qu'un
modeste aficionados sont férus de
tauromachie votre modestie ne vous
empêche pas de posséder la fia nada ce
matin la plus belle des environs de
mexico vous savez mon cher au taquet le
pied j'aimerais déposé cette force s'il
ne tenait qu'à moi donne félipe ma fille
juanita seraient des gens engagés avec
vous mais la voici vous plaindre et vous
même votre cause señorita scène verte
indique nous parlions de vous avec votre
père oui je disais oh seigneur tampico
qu'à ma connaissance ton coeur ma pointe
encore parlé mais vous vous trompez père
chéri il a parlé tu aime quelqu'un à la
folie
jeudi
souvenirs
ciman
et je lire
garneau
j'avais compris c'est moi
salut bonjour
à
et je suis une
dur
et
oh
il m'a
à
genève
oh
ces conditions rendent mita il ne te
reste plus qu'à nous dire non de mon
futur gendre avant de partir pour la
course j'aurais nommé mon avion mais
d'abord veuillez me suivre mesdames et
messieurs la bière et la peau y que vous
entendez par là
à tout à l'heure dont empire
ce novillo dont elle parle ce n'est pas
moi je les ai compris à l'ironie de son
car
s'il existe un rival celui là il aurait
tort de me barrer la route je n'ai pas
l'habitude de voir mes désirs contrariés
autre faille repris maïs madani aussi
coelho
plus populaires du mexique il mérite sa
renommée ce fils d'un boulanger au
village et la flexibilité qu'illégale
ouvrage vélo et mon titre
et
salut tabou toutes les verts
salue mes bons amis final
son site et jacuzzi
les aventures périlleuses
mais
deux bataillons
non
ce vous posez de dépôt
defossez
le prélat
combien de froid auprès des ratés
plus forte et
dino
metz amoureux de ma jeunesse
bientôt la sienne mais ces ménages
sommes toujours malade
mais pour avoir c'est le désert
on le sent baiser que j'envie de santé
tout reste à prouver
elle a toujours ses prisons
séduisant
ils soient pas
ça va
vous
non
les gravats il est beau
et
elle
m
à
juninho enfants crainte est de la voir
au dôme felipe comme je suis content
pouvoir je n'oublierai jamais la façon
dont vous avez encouragé mes débuts
quand je n'étais qu'un pauvre gamin je
t'ai distinguer c'est que tu montrait
déjà des qualités peu commune chez les
garnements de ton âge notre niño a
toujours su le coeur bien attaché à et
tutti connaît d'encouragement bien
morelos il en faut pour poser comme toi
les banderilles basta ce n'est rien à
côté de tes estocade à chacun selon son
mérite je suis très fier de travailler
sous ses ordres
quant à quadri ce n'est pas de toi que
j'entendrais jamais d'une critique on
reproche erreur niño tu oublies la scène
que je t'ai fait quand tu es rentrée du
club avant-hier au petit jour la tête et
la bourse vide après une infernale
partie de poker santa maría très bien
fait parler donc tampico vous m'avez
obligé cette nuit là en me prêtant la
somme dont j'avais besoin pour régler
mattel de jeu j'ai chez moi l'argent
pour vous rembourser si j'avais pensé
vous rencontrer les roms cela me presse
pas niño j'ai confiance en toi à l'on
vient voir les belles choses que mata
longue on nous prépare pour la dernière
grande corrida de l'année je vous suis
donc tombé vous
présenterez messieurs mon gars on va
dire à ton maître de la part de monsieur
m'a stopek que nous voudrions visiter sa
canadair il ya mois et un visiteur
illustre dont la venue va révolutionner
des invités oui a lancé un aficionado
frein c'est même mieux que cela provoque
ça vient seniors monsieur masse kopeck
et mon imprésario josé mast peine master
pec ça ne lui dit à rihanna toile va moi
je suis phrase 14 jérôme phrase 14 h 4
ça ne nous dit pas davantage aux
frasques à tokyo les toiles de cinéma la
vedette mondiale haut de l'écran et
c'est moi qui sors pour la belle cible
des mystères de la planète il n'a pas vu
des mystères c'est un idiot allez va
nous annonce donc si c'est ta faute
voyons ne me connaît pas ici et on ne me
connaît pas parce que tu ne vas pas
lancé pas lancé
j'ai commandé mille affiches double que
l'envié de ton dernier film le roi de
l'arène j'ai envoyé ta biographie à tous
les journaux de mexico ce matin on m'a
livré dix mille prospectus d'illustrer
ton portrait tient toute la page et de
l'autre côté ton nom est dix fois plus
gros que le titre du film mais je suis
cinq fois plus important qu est-ce qui
fait l'argent ça n'est pas le scénario
du pid c'est la petite engueulade bibi
qui est photogénique comme des rats de
l'eau bénite et télévisio génie et tout
à la boutique
flavell guère que 10 des mois qu'on se
retourne est déjà sur moi car sans
vouloir me tape t j'étais une vraie
beauté
les autres bébés et bb&t mamane de 28 et
sitôt qu'elle me voyait toutes les dames
bayer chacune criaient ils à quelque
chose de plus nette c'est
sur la rue sa visite il devienne son
papa ces souches à son charme et sa
plastique que les autres ne pas me
lorient du haut jusqu'en bas le petit
fils d'achille aux états chuchoter n'ya
pas où ça va tu veux que ce pause béria
je n'ai pas l'air important de monsieur
il remonte à je n'ai pas ses terres la
rue belle isle blessure quand à mr
et je n'ai pas de chapeau aux chevaliers
ni l'héritier qu'avenue morlaix il n'est
pas non plus l'été répondit de laurel et
hardy
oui mais voilà j'ai autre chose que ce
soit
c
pour la musique qui viennent mon papa
c'est mon chaton charme l'arctique que
les autres n'ont pas et devant nous
charmer pour a uni sa ou physique me dit
papa y en a pas tout soit vous à bâtir
dans tout le ciel
tout ce que tu viens de me dire j'en
conviens oui entretien convient mais tu
ne sais pas me tirer parti elle viendra
attendant rapproche et ont filmé un
trottoir tout ça trop tard de quoi ai-je
l'air vis-à-vis 2006 thompson a c'est à
cause de cette veuve joyeuse ah ah ah là
là ce que tu es passé dont je ne suis
pas pêcher en californie j'ai distingué
mitigé si entre cet annuaire atrix elle
en a été flatté au point de l'inviter à
faire un séjour dans sa magnifique
plantations de canne à sucre à honolulu
ouais j'ai aidé que jérôme fra scatter
ne serait pas fâché de se succéder à feu
monsieur thomson comme propriétaire de
la plantation et de faire son beurre
avec le sucre de canne monsieur basse
kopeck notre contrat ne vous autorise
pas fracturé les serrures de ma vie
privée ne t'emballe pas jérôme ta jeune
américaine m'a l'air d'un charmant
papillon qui vole vers tout ce qu'ils
voyaient des prouesses à l'écran il y en
a mis plein la vue mais que passe sur sa
route une autre vedette homme d'état
ténor ou boxer et au lieu d'être dans
les cannes à sucre tu seras dans les
weppes encore une fois monsieur masque
pec laisser mes choux tranquille et
occupez vous de vos oignons mais tiens
voilà justement ta belle conquête
à très chers amis quelle heureuse
surprise jean messieurs bonsoir cadors
ce qui m'attire i6 maintenant ce n'est
pas seulement l'agrément de votre
compagnie qué vous venez pour les
taureaux nous pour atteindre héros que
le port héros plus célèbre du mexique ni
newcits coelho il paraît qu'il est aussi
bon qu'il est pro à ces gens là sont
bien sûr fait d'un jeune garçon boucher
en rupture d'abattoirs pourtant
combattre taureau furieux montceau n'y a
rien du tout et moi qui vous parle dans
ma dernière production le roi de l'arène
eh bien j'ai tué est un toxique en test
du premier coup d'épée ça nous avoir
appris elle était née comme ça
ça ça c'est du sport ça c'est autre
chose que de taquiner avant le suivant
arrange le pauvre bête à cornes
je voudrais bien connaître ce mignon à
moi si justement le propriétaire de la
ganaderia monsieur matin longue seniors
mata longo je suis votre serviteur je
suis heureux de vous revoir seniors
masters et je reviens au mexique avec
deux de mes amis que vous me permettrez
de vous présenter mais si ceux-ci
thomson donnelly
et jérôme phrase 14 dont le seul nom
nous dispensons prince qatari
face 14 les pâtes dentifrices alors
monsieur
mille pardons oui en france 14 lycées
c'est vous qui venez d'installer le tout
à l'égout aka kool où la mode l'homme je
la célébrité ne sort mis des patates
militaire ni départ ça donne du tout à
l'égout mais du cinéma oui mon ami est
une grande vedette de l'écran monsieur
je m'excuse mais vous venez mais
peut-être pas le cinéma aussi j'adore
charlie chaplin et et durs de la ferme à
bombay selon bien fait leur temps
saignant là vous désirez voir magana dr
oui monsieur et aussi ce fameux matador
music when and other d'enseignants si
vous voulez me suivre il est justement
par la fenêtre de dios au pôle mer à je
ne crois pas que je me plairait au
mexique mois à les partants de 10,6
masque
personnes vous avez reçu mon billet oui
voilà niño pour que je donne ainsi
rendez-vous un jeune homme il a fallu un
motif sérieux ne le devine et vous pas
je n'osais pas croire à mon bonheur
ronit je vous aime depuis si longtemps
sans avoir jamais osé vous parlez vous
aussi une part les niño je vous croyais
inaccessible et puis la fille du riche
mata longo moi je suis fils d'un
forgeron de puebla tu m'a toujours plu
niño mais c'est à ta dernière course que
j'ai senti que je ne pourrai jamais être
qu'à toi le cirque a tremblé les
acclamations qui valait vers toi et moi
aussi j'aurais voulu voler vers toi pour
te crier mon amour remise cette gloire
ce c'était bien peu de choses à côté de
la récompense que tu m'as france maman
prend cet anneau niño tu vois j'ai le
semblable à mon doigt désormais je suis
tiennent pour la vie il ne me quittera
jamais maintenant je vais dire à mon
père le nom de mon art view pourvu
qu'ils consentent le rêver si vous je ne
peux pas croire qu'il va se réaliser
aurais tu peur de ton bonheur oui prenez
d'abord j'en ai peur
n'hésitez pas c'est pas
bon du tout
j'ai pas conseillé par un autre
seul
et
maya
oui
e
g
cent maisons s'est pas fait
monique qui me connaît bien tu laisses
et je ne parle de rien et plus tu le
froid mais nombreuses explorer
les taureaux les plus forts je ne sais
pas
mais restée le tollé
mon
grand
mon plaisir c'est d'être audacieux je
n'ai pas mal ni diable des dieux
j'aimais tout posé j'adore mon père il
explose
des fois
c'est nul à m'embrasser tous pareils
100 m oblige les habitants
oui
bon
j'ai bon
oui j'ai passé par train
oh
oui
et
c'est pas
sans rappeler c'est pas pour elle
viens dans les bras
qui viennent utile maintenant de vous
demander le nom de votre novio salir
tampico une jeune fille de chez-nous
n'abandonne célèbre que l'homme qui sera
son époux mon père j'espère que mon
sport à votre agrément mais certainement
puisque tu l'a décidé ainsi cette
décision vous déplaire et el señor motta
longue non parce qu elle j'aurais un
genre donc il me fera au l'air mais des
ennemis prétendre que tu as un vice que
je redoute entre tous il paraît que tu
aies joué c'est vrai si tu m'aimes niño
tu nous auras plus sévère de motta longo
quand le serai mariée je jure sur le
christ de ne jamais toucher une carte
dont tampico croyez que je regrette vous
savez que mes préférences mois soit plus
question au thé vous de présenter votre
futur gendre avait des grandes
admiratrices qui devait visiter voir
qu'à des rires quand sa compagnie une
rivale déjà bien ma frite nous la lui
feront visiter ensemble jamais avec vous
mes enfants au revoir dont ans puis
c'est insensé ocme préféré ce sequel au
un garçon que j'ai tirée du ruisseau qui
serait rien sans moi
mais patience
les hommes de marc haas ne pratique pas
le pardon des offenses
j'avais fait sa fortune je causerait sa
ruine à l'instant matin longo vient
d'obtenir une idée
voici du monde et loyaux
tout un groupe fort début entourant
hamissi g6 thompson laquelle est tout
talent ne vient-elle pas de voir la mort
de près les faits le taureau le plus
dangereux de tout la ganaderia le féroce
à roubion a pris ombrage probablement de
la robe rouge de jesse il l'a chargé
poursuivi renversé et il aurait piétinée
et tué à coups de cornes si ninio avec
courage et adresse était intervenu pour
l'école et le sauvage animal aussi
l'exaltation de jesse et l extrême au
grand dépit du vanni de phrases 14 parce
que si vous saviez je sais je sais j'ai
tout vu je m'apprêtais à faire un saut
de 10 mètres pour voler à votre secours
quand monsieur ligne aussi coelho a cru
devoir intervenir c'est un héros il a
risqué sa vie c'est mon métier au tout
ce que j'ai vous appartient monsieur
ligne où je suis à vous de toute entière
c'est beaucoup mais c'est trop quoi
c'est la fiancée pour vous servir
gracias monsieur ligne au gilet vous
applaudir tantôt à votre corrida ya
toutes les autres mais j'ai presque 14
suivez-moi aux gens n'aiment pas le
mexique moi mes amis niño va se préparer
pour la corrida de cet après-midi avant
son départ je vous propose de boire
succès d'une offre de manille
je voudrais te dire un mot avant ton
départ à votre disposition dont tampico
niño que répondre es tu si l'on se
demandait de relance et a épousé juanita
mata longo je répondrais que je préfère
renoncer à l'avenir à merveille fera sur
toi je me fais poser cette question que
pourrait prouver ton amour c'est tout ce
que vous avez à me dire non je viens de
la devise et tout à coup que je suis
sorti sans argent or je vais au club de
se part il se peut que je fasse une
petite partie avant la corrida veux-tu
me rendre la somme que je t'ai prêter je
vous l'envoie tout de suite mais fait
mieux apporte là toi même tu boiras ça
va faire avec nos camarades nous
partirons ensemble pour les arènes
entendu de ne pas plus je compte sur toi
señorita tous mes voeux de bonheur à
bientôt seigneur m'a talent go à bientôt
allez viens
ricardinho va venir au club tiens j'ai
entendu ne va pas au club niño pourquoi
mort elle-même méfie de tampico et de
ricardo son complice comme chante tu la
donnes ton piquant m'a toujours protégé
écoute ton ami niño chronique toi aussi
tu devras pour moi mais voyons qu'il
avait demandé ma main à mon père nos
fiançailles ont dû lever s'est
cruellement tout à l'heure quand il m'a
félicité il avait un étrange regard soit
prudent mon niño songe qu'à présent tu
as la responsabilité de deux existences
la tienne est la mienne si tu mourrais
je mourrai nous vivons tous les deux
alors à tout à l'heure aux arènes
une heure plus tard niño ainsi qu'il
avait promis rejoint temps à pic au club
des aficionados joue et paix tant pis
quand le fait boire et lui donne eu pour
adversaire au poker un infâme tricheurs
du nom de lopes ninian s'aperçoit
bientôt de la fourberie il a insulte la
paix ce qui sort son couteau n'ignore
afin de se défendre saisi également une
arme un coup malheureux niño tu
l'appelles temps pic alors jouant les
protecteurs fait sortir précipitamment
niño du club et lui ordonne de se cacher
le question pour lui les stocker ce soir
aux arènes et tampico bassement répand
la fable que ninio s'est dérobé par peur
du taureau puis il ordonne aux jeunes
hommes de quitter à jamais le mexique ne
pouvons aussi résoudre le pauvre niño se
réfugie dans une maison de danse de
mexico où présentement une insistance
s'est mêlé aux anciens horaires gens du
peuple aficionado applaudissent les
danses locales
à
là
ouais
hélas
le mot
non
à
pour moi
donc tant pis coût entre dans le cabaret
il va droite ligne attendant la ligne
haut je savais être vérifiées tant pis
je n'oublie pas que je me tais sauvé du
supplice des assassins qu'à une
condition c'est que tu t'engages sur
l'honneur a quitté mexique d'extérieur
et l'ordre donne ton picot
quel intérêt avez vous de vous
débarrasser de moi comprends-tu pas pu
conserver dont les jeux un criminel que
j'ai arraché à la justice ou un rival
que vous avez arraché à sa fille en robe
relâché par passion si on part
connaissait n'ayez crainte nul ne
s'aviserait de reconnaître niño dans la
misérable et peuvent que vous en avez
pré écoute bien ceci si tu ta devise est
d'en paraître avant que je te donne
l'ordre de partir je n'hésiterai pas de
dénoncer gilles conserver la dame
catherine lopez et il me suffirait de
délier alors de certains témoins attend
ici mes ordres et pense à ce que je t'ai
dit je te laisse
vous saurez bien entre les mains de cet
homme que faire mon dieu merci vous
voyez monsieur pascal janin vendre ici
ni nous pour ce costume maintenant que
je suis comme ça que vous m'avez reconnu
en tout de suite et je bénis le hasard
qui me rassure sur votre compte je vous
croyais mort je regrette de ne pas lui
on ne dit pas cela si vous saviez bon je
me doute qu'un drame a dû se passer dans
votre vie on n'abandonne pas sans un
motif grave une pareille gloire il
paraît que j'ai eu peur vous alles on
dont je dois arrive tout sauf cela merci
et je tiens à vous dire ceci niño si
vous êtes malheureux venez chez moi à
honolulu vous y trouverez l'asile rêver
en alu
un jour
ce
seul
je suis
le
entre
on sait tous
et
c'est eux
oui c'est le pbd qui doivent s'activer
gaudy
ah bon
là
je fais
et
je
je veux
est
donné
m
oui vous avez raison madame ce serait le
paradis mais hélas il n'est pas fait
pour les hommes de mon espèce
voici votre ami excusez moi je dois
rester calme réfléchi si ninio
adieu seniors n'ont pas à dieu
patron fait fort c'est ici qu'il faut
recevoir parce qu'à tort à la
disposition de nous allez faites entre
les admirateurs il reste présent
restants
seniors c ra salvatore seigneurie passe
profitez de ces quelques minutes que je
vous accorde pour contempler en chair et
en os l'illustrent à ce rapport
c'est moi qui suis le roi
la reine
on admirera la
forêt la semaine et touche aussi le roi
à chablis à vouloir aller à levallois un
bond à 7
c'est moi le plus adroit
renaissance
la graine ce qu'ils disent
nouvelle
quand il faut tourner une scène qui se
déroule dans l'arène fait toujours le
matador
en fait toujours la mise à mort
devant la caméra l'ouragan cette boîte
plus tard actes de vol
le temple heures comme au top les
cinémas nantais
on a mieux mon allure anciens
adios amigo adios muchachos
radio sans but les uns dios aux mulets
les
amazones tiny les berceaux et leur art
des dj goûts et aux aléas wenger est
face à moi la clé
alors je le match où je le matd pas
alors je ne m'attends pas à aller elle
est allée à des restes là mon petit yens
wii mc trop bas soit jeune teaser non
mais faut pas avoir peur on ne me
regarde pas comme une chose qui m'a dit
tu vas me faire pleurer
au je préfère le trouver tout de suite
moi et moi à la maca là je finissais
tout le pastis c'est moi qui ce minois
l'avoir atteint
loto
de l'ape
gaver
des yeux le foudroie il fait le signe de
croix guillaume budget pouvoir l'égide
du commun
c'est
qu'il me
quelques jours plus tard ont lieu aux
arènes de mexico les dernières courses
de temps de l'année celle où le rubio
doit pas être le dangereux animal
inquiète les matadors mais il a attiré
une foule considérable le grade à son
comble juanita et là dans la loge
officielle avec son père et dont tampico
la jeune fille est sans nouvelles de
niño et sans tourmente autant qu'elles
sont ni tom elle ne se doutent guère que
ça durait n'y de leur s est au service
de tampico et subtilise les lettres que
ninio lui adressent chaque jour dans
l'aurès souffle d'autre part à roanne et
à une attitude moins distante envers le
seigneur tampico ainsi tories celui ci à
faire rechercher une ligne par les
services du dictateur ciprian auprès
duquel il est tout puissant et la
malheureuse roanne et à ceux contraints
à sourire mais
mais précis que dans la chapelle des
toréadors se glisse un matador enveloppé
dans un vaste mentaux ces lignes son
vieux camarade le picador morelos le
reconnaît avec stupeur ligne aux sétois
métier d'une imprudence folle tant pis
vrai le jeu n'y tient plus pourquoi
l'état ne répondait pas à mes lettres
cats ont pu lui raconter pour arriver à
la détacher de moi tu respires pas lui
parler au milieu de cette fouille pour
la revoir je suis prêt à toutes les
folies
le monde
ce vrai
ceux-là
soit
e
ouais
ça
les
le père ly
oh
reconnue
series
dur
nous
ça
il en veut
ce mois
oui c'est vrai
lee
le faire
simple non
morales offs entraîne réunion car voici
ma stoppait faisant visiter les arènes
après ce capteur ainsi que la mystique
qui décident thompson bientôt leur
parviennent des exams à sion
bravo rend bien ils roulent par le
taureau sournois et brutale a blessé son
matador et maintenant la foule réclame
hammamet mais qu'est-ce qui crie mais on
dirait greentree face 14 mais qu'est ce
tu me veulent attends je vais voir des
publics doit être fâché
j'ai toujours dit que je suis quelque
part je ne m'appartient plus en vous
lisant tandis que j'adore le mexique en
amical tuiles dit monsieur masque fait
qu on ne trouve plus de matador pour
combattre le rouge cette mexicaine
qu'elle aux nouilles on ne compte plus
que sur as salam et ben alors qu'est ce
qui l'attend celui là que tu te décides
sétois quoi là haut ils ont tous
admirent et on estocade dans le bois de
la reine ils disent qu'il n'y a que toi
pour venir à bout de vous offrir ce que
tort qu'elle triomphe si vous êtes
stocker le bois évidemment avec messi le
taureau maison comme vous l'êtes à tous
les sports rio mais je suis rompu mais
enfin je ne veux pas être défendue si
jérôme à l'isi je serai si fière de vous
tenez pour vous encourager je vous
embrasse mon eau
aux femmes de shishou j'ai envie de dire
que vous acceptez
france 14 il faut y aller taquiner cette
grosse bête n'était pas loupé si tu me
lance notre publicité reçoit un coup
mortel oui mais si je marche c'est moi
tu leur soient leurs études dgo tu nous
lis
exxon a dit paul mecs a vu la longueur
de ses cornes tu rates un médecin peut
tu vas vis et 200 comptes à rouiba mais
moi je le suis pas content géraud je te
jure que tu ne risques rien tu vas pas
me raconter qu'il a les cordes en
gélatine le rubio est déjà sur les
genoux moi j'aimerais bien qu'il se soit
tout à fait seigneur fasse 14 je vous
apporte votre instrument de combat un
même mais je ne veux pas combattre
monsieur matin dans mon beau rôle et si
vous ne venez pas ils vont tout démolir
alors vous préférez que le jeu soit
démoli mois écoutez si vous manquez
votre estocade tous les cafés adore et
celle des banderilleros ce qui à droite
à côté de vous pour détourner le
tourangeau
conférence aussi j'étais le sueur qui se
l'est fait
d'arriver voici vp et la moulette et
l'estocade ici à eau mais çà et là
contenue grâce à
la couche glaciale les robots mais
la rue mais les cornes aussi son pointu
pas comme ça et je ne tremble pas pour
moi non je pense aux taureaux à sa mère
à cette pauvre vieille marche pour
remettre ça mais je n'ai rien contre lui
et il n'a rien contre moi mais un festif
à la société protectrice des animaux
j'en ai peur que ça chez ben
tu pourrais pas me faire donner une
cigarette et un verre de rhum
prince 14 à peine est-il dans l'arène
que le rubio le charge frasques et or se
révèle alors un véritable champion de
course à pied le taureau de la pointe de
sa corne lattes important dans la partie
la plus charnue de son individus la
folle multiplie les cris et les huées
les capés à dar détourne l'animal et on
emporte le fras 14 évanouie l'euro
millions reste le grand vainqueur
ligne qui dans l'ombre bien et
d'assister à tout cela prend alors une
décision mais le fou ligne puisqu'il n'y
a plus de matador dans la penderie ya je
vais leur montrer si j'ai perdu rubio el
niño songe que don tant pis aux diables
dans de tampico cd combattre pour le
recueil de mon nom et pour l'amour de
marque juanita tient les ignobles
pénètre dans la lys l'épée à la main
la mise à mort
n'ignorez stocks le port aux tombes
m
et
elle
à part ça
m
regardez
à
et
il est porté en triomphe
martine aubry et le ps vous le
connaissez seniors tampico cela me
convient de porter en triomphe nous
voulons avoir la preuve de son crime son
couteau qu'on a trouvé auprès des
victimes c'est que l'arrêté ici après
une telle victoire et sort du dictateur
cyprien nos idiots à manquer à sa parole
c'est y aller
ne faut pas que poignée d'artistes à son
arrestation
je suis tout entendu je vais prévenir
nignon
geste sur nous
amira religieux
parmi là où est il witi guide parce qu'à
tort au mit qui vous parle de se
plaindre je vous parle de notre hui
juninho chicoine bon ça c'est un coup
terrible pour la publicité brasse 14
récemment matador après la course on va
se faire écharper si je ne le connais
pas moi chenillo n'ai jamais vu que son
portrait enfin où se trouve le torero
qui a combattu le roupillon a fait c'est
moi c'est moi qui ai combattu leurs
goûts bureau vous avec 1
c'est plus fort que de jouer aux
bouchons non seulement j'ai risqué ma
peau vous savez quoi on vous accuse vous
n'aviez pas besoin de vous battre jeudi
cher constaté match j'avais le soleil
dans la nuit pendant mon année on and on
est tous mal également
je suis victime d'une erreur
profitons de leur méprise
le voici transportés un mois plus tard
aux îles hawaii à waikiki dans la très
belle villa de jesse thompson c'est un
décor de rêve
il est 10 heures du soir
et par les baies du grand rôle la nuit
tous apportent le parfum des fleurs
autour de jesse d'autres jeune femme
belle et gracieuse comme elle est comme
elle élégamment vêtues de mousseline
légère forme et un tableau savoureux les
invités masculins smoking clair ou ce
cancer blanc sont regroupés dans un
autre angle du salon nous remarquons
frasques à tort et nous remarquons aussi
une ligne haut à 6 un peu à l'écart tout
est calme souriant charmant tout respire
le bonheur
à laura
ouais
oh
ça
et
cher le système sauf qu'elle soupex qui
vous êtes la meilleure maîtresse de
maison de neuilly du voilà vous êtes
trop indulgent sachez qu'elle est douce
boatman que vous nous avez ramené de vos
voyages
madame j'ai entendu votre question je
suis frasques à tort la vedette mondiale
et provençal charme
mais où nous ne m'avait donc pas vu à
l'écran honolulu ne va pas beaucoup au
cinéma non on laisse cela aux indigènes
away au jeu regrette le mexique moi non
on vous y faire encorner on vous fixe
ans de prison par erreur mais au moins
on sait qui vous êtes mais ici quoi où
quand
je ne vous parle pas de ce gentleman
mais si son nom mais de l'autre la
barbie qui allaient s'y mélanger le
seigneur ou du ps c'est un riche
industriel perry et il est chargé de les
représenter signaux perez
signaux perez pour ces faits c'est moi
qui parle le seigneur julio perez messi
serait madame vous habitez le pérou aux
seniors oui et quelques unes que ville
je ne suis pas le seul signe opérer
cette climat oui c'est ça lima et kelly
et votre occupation une occupation
le taureau le seigneur perez fait de
l'élevage en grand il possède la bad
immense pâturages des peu débat j'ai
voté les cochons noirs
ne soyez pas distrait je vous en prie
vous avez failli vous trahir pour le
pire ou vous avez aucun nom de villes de
ce pays bas possible mais je sais j'ai
eu tort d'accepter l'asile que vous
m'avez vous êtes fous d'abord je suis un
autre compromettant un homme traqué qui
peut vous attirer des engrais n'y ait
rien personne ne reconnaîtrait niño ans
julio perez et puis julio perez se rend
compte qu'il n'est pas à sa place chez
vous alors le pauvre taureau ignore les
les belles manières très vite apprises
les belles manières croyez-moi niño
c'est moins difficile qu'une mise à mort
vous êtes bonne attention voici meister
clark le chef de la police shir mi6
thompson qu'elle ravissante soit au
grâce à mes invités mystères clar mais
permettez moi de vous présenter le
senior julio perez de l'ina de l'image
dans le pérou enchanté et seniors
misison je m'excuse d'être obligés de
nous quitter mais on vient m'apporter un
câble on me signale de mexico qu'un
assassin échappée de là-bas se serait
réfugiée à honolulu nécessaire oui un
certain chic aux élus torero de sa
profession qui a tué un ami du dictateur
qui priaient à tout hasard je vais faire
fouiller tous les bouges où peut se
cacher un individu de cette sorte je
vous reconduis mais ce cercle a donné
signes apparaissent je vous suis madame
ta personne ne m'a dit à moi
à oui je regrette le mexique
si pascal
et oui oui kolani ma petite servante de
noir ou i moi moi tout seul
comme il ya plein
d'activités ou à de la haine à
abattre au moins tu m'as vu
merci quand même mimi comme ça
merci de location et chaque nom sans
façon j'attendrai la prochaine et ce
produit sanguin maintenant si toi et moi
comment comment tu me fait tiquer
comique à la mi temps je me suis
fais avec mon personnel au sujet des
admiratrices un peu dans tous les pays
puis je vous dirais moreau je vous en
prie je voudrais vous parler de votre
matamore niño chicuelo avec qu'est ce
qui peut vous charmer 6e tiller le tueur
de marge non seulement c'est un bandit
mais c'est un homme mal élevé à table il
coupe son père avait un couteau et il
casse les pattes de langoustes avait la
place à aspen il est plus à ceux nés en
france note euros est ce une allusion à
mon combat contre le rck au combat c'est
beaucoup dire mais si j'ai tourné le dos
madame c'est que j'avais le soleil dans
l'oeuf
poché donner assez de preuves de ma
bravo dragomir le genre oui je suis
excusé moi je suis un peu fatigué bruit
dans les mystères de la physique au
pétard de sort ça peut pas continuer
vous pouvez le matamore tient à dans le
jardin à tête seniors chicuelo
plus bad ont signé en france 14 ici je
me nomme perez
les seniors chicuelo j'ai deux mots à
vous dire vous écoute
et bien s'ignorent chicuelo vous me
gêner je vous joins
formidablement d'abord vous êtes un
meurtrier un ennemi public monsieur
frasques à tort on peut devenir un
ennemi public comme vous dites sans être
un méchant tome on a fait un bon match
arles vous me gêner c'est vrai moi la
police non monsieur dont jérôme fra
satan est pas un mouchard jérôme frantz
14 lutte loue également avait rival mois
un rival oui oui je veux j'en conviens
j'en conviens dans l'arène je suis
peut-être moins brillant que vous mais
je voudrais vous voir au studio 142
projecteurs quand le metteur en scène
écrit on tourne et qu'il faut faire une
déclaration passionnée à une petite
poule de cinéma qui vient de vous
traiter de près le coin à la cantine des
artistes mais je le prétends pas vous
faire concurrence à les grands noms mais
auprès de geci thompson oui ici d'aller
pas nier que vous lui faites la course -
oui mais pas du tout les laisser au
mexique une fiancée que j'adore et à qui
j'ai juré fidélité
tenez voici une autre en option sai qui
ne me quitte jamais oh mais mes 1000 g
si vous venez pour elle que de
l'affection et leurs connaissances au
maire simoneau
si vous êtes vous n'êtes pas car vous
êtes chicuelo
à nouveau ça c'est une bonne non mais tu
sais comment situation devenait
intenable si je ne retrouve pas au
mexique où mon imprésario matam pour
tourner il faut que je me marie alors si
on est bien ou mal tourné oui ah non au
revoir seigneur france 14 oui est tout à
votre service vous
savez
maintenant précipiter nous la
prenons ce bouquet de fleurs dans ce
vase et faisons une petite europe
d'issia
je sais charmante et si coquette un
souvenir d'un soir si beau daigné
accepter ces fleurs est que j'ai cueilli
sur le piano aux
g6
mitigé si c'est moi c'est moi jérôme
phrase 14
vous offrir ce quelques fleurs merci
mais c'est pour cela que non non non non
non ce n'est pas tout ce que j'ai à vous
offrir moi mon corps mon coeur et ma
main moussé france catalans donne avant
de me répondre attendez de connaître une
nouvelle une excellente nouvelle guen
niño ne vous aime pas du tout il adore
toujours sa fiancée conseiller vous
arrive vient de me le dire à la star et
bah ça arrange
je vous prie de vous mêler de ce qui
vous regarde de ne pas déranger pour mme
obsédé par vos déclarations de chira me
permet je vous en prie laissez-moi vous
m'avez donné la migraine en vérité je
m'en vais mais enfin vous me permettrez
d'ouvriers du tout ah bon abiet eh ben
je suis tombé sur un d'être
mignonne toujours juanita je m'en
doutais allons il faut employer les
grands moyens
saignant niño vous m'avez appelé il
s'estime sol oui génial recevoir les
journaux en voici un de mexico j'ai
pensé que vous seriez content d'avoir
des nouvelles de votre pays certes je
vous remercie à tout à l'heure
ayant
toujours des troubles intérieurs le
général rivard aise et celle de fomenter
une révolte contre le dictateur ciprian
on annonce les fiançailles des seniors
philippe est un picot avec la scénariste
ronit matalon
et voilà
les enfants
depuis longtemps picot est si riche
l'anneau qu'elle m'avait donné
daigneault je suis tiennent pour la vie
verizon
koweit où vous
mais pour moi
on amadou d'heure
seulement
nous sommes
et
c'est mal
et puis 20 jours
c'est sûrement donne
les bleus
qui ont su
vaud
c'est bien mais forêt
étaient brandis
sa fille et de sa mort
nous avons su
ouf
écolo
pas douter
mon seul
voyons
concert
e
déception
c'est faux
et
désespéré
ligne jet de loin de lui la nos qui
symbolise l amour de roanne et à mai
geci qui entre à cet instant vois le
geste et ramasse l'anneau
niño vous avez de la peine un peu oui on
venait je ne veux pas vous laisser seuls
avec votre chagrin où voulez-vous
m'emmener à ma plantation nous arrivons
au petit jour et vous assisterez all you
all you we une réjouissance champêtre
que les indigènes ont préparé pour moi
la vie on la voyait vous réserve encore
de belles heures venez niño peu après la
sortie de jesse et de l'ignon le
serviteur pâte introduit deux visiteurs
et nous reconnaissons le brave moreno et
vêtus d'habits masculin juan mata mata
longo veuillez donc prévenir le seigneur
paraissent que nous l'attendons morelos
la senior perez c'est niño il a donc
changé de nom señorita juanita forcément
puisqu'il est accusé d'un crime
attention alors ne parlons que s'il
vient seulement n'ayez crainte j'ai trop
de raison de me méfier de cette famille
si ce jeu si thomson allait mourinho
elle veut me le prendre si je vous ai
suppliés m'accompagnant navailles c'est
que je sentais mon amour en danger je me
demande comment votre père aura pris
cette fugue que m'importe quand je ne
lui pardonne pas d'avoir essayé de me
contraindre à épouser cet odieux tampico
tampico n'est pas homme à se résigner
quand nous avons débarqué ne m'a semblé
apercevoir son complice cette canaille
de ricardo card aurait donc voyager avec
nous pour nous espionner ou pour
dénoncer niño aux autorités hawaïennes
silence quelqu'un
mais si vous faites là nous attendons le
seigneur perez il n'ya pas avec mara ou
la plantation avec madame oui en théorie
un pique-niqué paix ou à quoi mais t'es
tu l'aimés dame ou en foyer morelos et
lui est-ce qu'ils l'aiment mois pote à
moi
toujours plus fois dit que les femmes
merci de renseignement venez morelos où
allez-vous à la plantation mitigé si
dire que j'ai peut être entrepris un
voyage pareil
pour trouver un infidèle revoyez à
la catho ah oui et oui mais voilà kolani
me voilà oui a dit me to you ou mais pas
si toi veut pas épouser mois wattignies
oui oui je sais tu me
trouves à tour à tour comique congo où
il lui dit paco compact pour rim
mais ça paye à la poule n'a pas empêché
bonheur j'y sens dans mon petit coeur
équipe qui allume
les nouilles ou
soit nous l'ouvrirons content du tout
ils vont sapajou
chine inhalé beaucoup je n'ai pas de
paris j tant pis
pour
nous doudou il étudie toujours
mais si tu payes à sa fin oui et les
mouchoirs n'a pas de ballons soir
nettoyez grèce
mégi qui pouvons nous écoutons
je reste chez toi et moi
m
jouer
sa
part
journalisme au départ
doudou
quelques instants plus tard nous sommes
avec tous les invités dans la plantation
de jesse thompson les indigènes vont
procéder à la cérémonie annuelle du luot
suit une tendance qui rappelle l'époque
où les îles hawaii était une sorte de
paradis terrestre
tous les planteurs hommes femmes enfants
sont regroupés devant les plans de canne
à sucre et d'ananas la danse se
déroulera tandis que la lumière du jour
montrera lentement à l'apparition du
soleil les chants etc latran et la rumba
se déchaîna
cela commence
on
oh
et
tous
vous savez
m
mais bon
on
hu
pas
le prix semble
mes chers jeunes je suis très heureuse
que mon royaume primitif et mes sujets
plus primitives sont encore vos et plus
si vous voulez vous donner la peine de
passer dans cette grande tente une
collation vous y attend
bingo demeurait un instant je vous prie
j'ai à vous parler
niño parlez moi franchement comptez vous
retourner au mexique pour quoi faire je
suis à l'aise mais public jeune et plus
madoff via alors pourquoi ne resteriez
vous pas en avant avec moi je ne puisse
abuser de votre hospitalité je ne vous
propose pas a dit rester comme mon
invité mais comme mon mari votre mari
mois aux nih niaux je ne sais quels sont
vos sentiments à mon égard mais moi je
vous aime votre fiancée vous a trahi
votre vie est en danger avec moi vous
êtes en sécurité si la police d'ici vous
inquiétez nous partirions pour l'euro
seniors g si je suis surpris bouleversé
mais mais nous ne pouvons pas le marié
les scrupules encore si juanita n'est
même plus moi je n'ai pas réussi à
l'oublier et je n'ai pas le droit de
disposer d'un hacker encore tout plein
d'elle
récit permettez moi de me retirer comme
ils l'aiment encore
à
le matamore à cesser de vous accaparer
comme vous voulez vous vous écoutez je
vous parle je vous écoute pas eh bien
j'ai si je ne peux plus tolérer que vous
me préférait un individu indigne de vous
je vais le tuer je ne vous conseille pas
déçus mais nous allons voir je vais de
ce pas lui l'annoncé de provocation ici
oui et bien j'y vais ou chambre est
décorée de la macarena de la corrida des
lois de la grotte où madame puisque
votre matador matador les matadors moi
je mate adour rêve être maintenant et je
sors quand l 211 tombe bien c'est
imbécile
misys thompson
ici je m'excuse d'avoir pénétré dans
votre propriété segnora mais ce n'est
pas à vous que je voulais voir vous
venez relance henning oui niño vous
m'avez volet i seniors à pourquoi êtes
vous venu dans mon pays pour me prendre
mon bonheur señorita ce n'est pas ma
faute si vous n'avez pas su vous
attachez votre 9 you mean you et comme
tous les hommes seniors à il peut être
faible avec une jolie femme qui se
jettent à sa tête mais je suis sûr
qu'ils n'aiment que moi remo si
singulière alors qu'il me demandait ma
main votre marque niño vous mentez cet
anneau qu'il a passé lui même à mon
doigt va confondre votre insolence on a
nos wii et l'anneau de fiançailles que
vous lui avez donné cette preuve ou
suffit-elle oui segnora vous avez gagné
après tout puisqu'il vous la donne et
mignot n'est pas l'homme que je croyais
gardez le et soyez heureuse moi ma vie
est finie adieu
l'échappée belle cependant parce qu'à
tort comme il l'avait fait imprudemment
a juré à provoquer en duel sans rival
niño la rencontre organisée par le chef
de police clark va avoir lieu dans un
paysage désertique aux environs
d'honolulu
voici le lieu du rendez vous monsieur
phrase 14 il n'est pas gay monsieur
clark c'est l'endroit rêvé pour un duel
à mort
vous vous croyez qu'il y aura un mort un
c'est inévitable avec le mode de combat
que vous avez choisi alors dites-moi si
l'un de nous deux et tuer je n'aurais
pas d'un humain surtout si c'est vous a
et vous avez de fortes chances de ne
partir d'ici que sur une civière et ben
vous êtes j'encourage en seniors que
yoplait est un tireur infaillible nous
parlons plus de ça au d'ailleurs le
voici mon adversaire
non je vous salue
mais si je vous rappelle les conditions
du combat chacun de vous fera feu à
volonté et à la distance qui lui plaît
et tout ce que je vous demande tout ce
que je demanderai à mon adversaire c'est
de ne pas rouvrir ma blessure n'ayez
crainte je viserai la tête avait à bord
rouge et européens vous pouvez utiliser
tous les accidents de terrain pour vous
dissimulez a très bien ça prête très
bien à rayons et bien nous allons tirer
la place il restera ici et fassent
s'éloignera à 50 mètres attention je
lance la pièce annoncé face saignant
face 14 c'est pile vous restez ici
naturellement puis le sais moi juste
pile et je vais encore avoir le soleil
dans le coma bellocchio seniors mignot
vous avez deux minutes pour vous
éloigner de 50 mètres c'est plus qu'il
n'en faut oui à l'égalité
face rester il
ne veut pas tuer cet idiot mais je vais
lui donner une sérieuse leçon et
maintenant bonne chance seniors frasques
à tort ou pour le jargon touchons du
bois au mas que j'aime d'entendre ça
niño n'a aucune intention de tuer ce
pauvre imbécile de france 14 et le duel
ne serait qu'une scène comique aussi par
fatalité le coup de carabine de france
14 lancers au petit bonheur ne blesser
gravement l'un des hommes de clark or le
chef de police vient précisément
d'identifier ligne outil qu elle il
accuse dont fera scatter de complicité
et voici nos deux amis contraint de
prendre la fuite unis dans le crime
niño n'a qu'une pensée rejoindre au plus
vite le mexique et se disculper auprès
de juanita il touche presque au but déjà
le voici avec frasques et heures dans
une passade aux environs de puebla il
peut apercevoir au pied de la montagne
la fia n'da de matha longue mais cette
montagne c'est un rôle tant ce volcan
c'est le terrible popocatépetl et dans
la nuit c'est l'éruption n'est union et
fera skater par miracle sont sains et
saufs mais la coulée de lave balle est
la sienne la de matha longue qui
lui-même péri dans le cataclysme
voilà juanita orphelines et ruiné la
malheureuse se réfugie aux environs de
mexico au couvent de notre dame de la
guadeloupe
niño ne tarde pas à le savoir il se
déguise en mendiante eux
parce qu'à tort en fait autant et les
voici tous deux devant la porte du
couvent
c'est là que maronite est en ligne au
nous voilà devant son couvent et vous
voyez que personne nous a reconnu les
faits il s'agit d'y pénétrer qu'allons
nous rencontrer assez bonne soeur oui
mais faisons une petite répétition dit
alors on comprend des voix de femmes
je vais essayer bon ben alors essayé
ce n'est pas pour
nous
une inaction
pour
vous
voilà ma place
et ne comprend pas
vous
pitié photo paul anciaux
qui sont refaites et tremblant un des
plis mation nous sommes hélas un foyer
st
nous sommes
seuls
nous sommes des femmes et pas des drames
nous sommes en vous confiant
et nous
selon me connesson
devant la
venez pitié de notre part
tétouan tv
c'est toi qui diot utile pour nous
vite et pour nos invités pour nos prix
des billets pour mot
pitié pour nos billets au mot
le
seigneur france 14 c'est à vous que
revient le mérite de cet investissement
et vous voyez que la pratique du cinéma
peut servir à quelque chose
la planche
je vous laisse pas mais j'ai plus peur
de se nomme que durant bio avec
l'accasion tour
que désirez-vous segnora ce maçon nous
sommes dépendants femme sans ressources
oui nous ne savons pas où passer la nuit
d'où venez vous mes soeurs des laveurs
accouchement de la vera cruz api ap
indien à pied vous voyez marc willemant
très cher mais vous parlez si nous les
avons ça quoi jerry pâte on met les
pieds et oui c'est la conséquence quand
vous
entrez mes soeurs notre règle nous
prescrit l'hospitalité théo gracias mam
et anglais se faisait
chapelle du couvent
juanita il a parmi les religieuses
agenouillé ligne ayant rejeté sa
défroque de mendiantes se glisse
derrière un pilier
il écoute ses voeux un pur élever leurs
prières jusqu'à lieu
à
c est mon
oh
m
e
mes filles laissez moi avec north
nouvelle postulants
mon enfant vous m'avez annoncé votre
volonté formelle d'abandonner le monde à
jamais oui ma mère à jamais dans le
monde tout n'est que leader lâcheté
trahison vous êtes bien jeune pour
parler ainsi votre amertume ne
viendrait-elle pas d'un amour déçu
qu'importe les motifs qui me pousse à
faire mansaly
mon enfant dieu n'est pas un pis-aller
votre noviciat ne vous en chêne pas
encore brillé mon enfant je vous laisse
je vais prier mamère
5 madone assisté mois fallait que
j'oublie niño comme il m'a oublié
sinon notre tour nous la police
dépêchons-nous ils viennent film on
ignore trop tard que voici tampico ces
policiers alors par exemple ces deux
hommes chacun d'eux va voir répondre
d'un meurtre leur procès sera vite
instruit seigneur me soirée le choix au
gesù passer par les arts martiaux n'ai
pas de préférence mon cher juanita
malgré tous les avertissements
vous disposez bien mal de votre coeur
que vous important dans picot vous
n'aurez jamais la charge c'est ce que
nous verrons à la prison
toujours
les événements se précipitent
mexico est en pleine révolution est
cependant obstiné dans sa haine tampico
donne l'ordre d'exécuter en place
publique ninian efface 14 un officier
s'approche de lui et quand un pic mois
ci du condamné merci seigneur niño
seniors phrase 14 mai prochain demi je
veux savoir le grand plaisir de vous
conduire moi-même au poteau d'exécution
là vous êtes vraiment trop gentil senio
j'ai oublié chercher la séniorité
juanita vous pourrez lui faire vos
adieux définitifs
veut mort et consoler à l'idée qu'elle
n'aime que moi et qu'elle ne sera jamais
votre farmall caldari
shell le général arrive à réchy tampico
l'hôtel de ville vient d'être repris par
mes partisans ils sont maîtres de tous
les points stratégiques
cipriano est en fuite la partie est
perdue pour vous froid qu
pirée ninaute chicuelo j'ai promis votre
grâce à votre charmante protectrice ce
sera mon don de joyeux événement merci
mon général et moi presque à tort j'ai
obtenu la liberté de mon ami rivarès oh
merci mon masque peut regretter et
saignant à picot une politesse en vaut
une autre je vous accompagnerai moi même
au contrôle exécution
mais si je vous dois la vie oui mais je
sais que la vie vous paraîtrait
insupportable sans une certaine personne
nous voulons l'envoyer chercher dans son
monastère soyez heureux niño la voilà
mon niño tussauds en l'état ni newmont
niño enfin
on
bon sang
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs la
radiodiffusion française vient de vous
présenter en l'émission différé au
soleil du mexique opérette on a deux
actes dans la drôme béziers on est
adhérent willemetz musique de maurice
yvain précis quelle en était la
distribution niño willy clément jérôme
fra skater maurice portera
mastec rené smit damping cours gilbert
morin matalon bourg georges fois morelos
jacques pruvost clark géniaux le chef
des algues voisine pierre roy c'est
jeanine michaud qui était jesse thompson
christian-jaque un one hits à charlotte
vacquiers kokkola ni marcel sanctionné
petit la supérieure les textes une
liaison était de denise vautrin mise en
ondes musicales jean etienne marie
enregistrement pierre henry vers les
solistes l'orchestré radio lyrique et
les choeurs de la radiodiffusion
française chef des choeurs marcel
briclot était placée sous la direction
de gilles gressier